No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没人会为了汉克的电子表格而去他的店里，他们是为了那份美味的披萨。但最近，店里变得冷清了。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，以帮助他判断自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小细节能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. Over the past several years, the rise of GLP1 drugs such as OZemPEC and Wagovi has changed the conversation around weight and obesity in the U.S. Once reserved for treating diabetes, GLP1s are now widely available. One recent survey found that 12% of American adults have taken a GLP1 medication
现在，汉克的店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。欲了解更多信息，请访问M365Copilot.com/work。过去几年里，Ozempic和Wegovy等GLP-1药物的兴起改变了美国关于体重和肥胖的讨论。GLP-1药物曾经仅用于治疗糖尿病，如今已广泛普及。最近的一项调查发现，12%的美国成年人服用过GLP-1药物，
and another 14% are interested in doing so. For many people, the drugs have been life-changing, But along with physical changes, people taking GLP-1s often need to navigate new mental health, emotional, and relationship concerns. Now mental health professionals are thinking about how best to support people through these challenges. So how do GLP-1 drugs work? What should people consider when they're deciding whether or not to take them? What affects both positive and negative might these medications have on mental health? How does weight loss affect people's relationships?
另有14%的人有兴趣尝试。对许多人来说，这些药物改变了他们的生活。但除了身体上的变化，服用GLP-1药物的人往往还需要应对新的心理健康、情绪和人际关系问题。现在，心理健康专业人士正在思考如何最好地支持人们度过这些挑战。那么GLP-1药物是如何起作用的？人们在决定是否服用时应该考虑什么？这些药物对心理健康会有哪些正面或负面的影响？减肥如何影响人们的人际关系？
with their family, friends, and partners, why is there still stigma around the use of GLP ones and how can patients navigate and protect themselves from that stigma? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Rachel Goldman,
与家人、朋友和伴侣的关系，为什么围绕GLP-1药物的使用仍然存在污名化，患者又该如何应对并保护自己免受这种污名化的影响？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是瑞秋·戈德曼博士，
a licensed psychologist in private practice in New York City and a clinical assistant professor in the Department of Psychiatry at NYU. Her practice focuses on stress management, eating behaviors, obesity treatment, and health behavior change. From 2011 to 2016, she served as senior psychologist at the Center for Obesity and Weight Management at Bellevue Hospital. In addition to her clinical work, Dr. Goldman is frequently featured as a health expert in the media, including as an expert panelist with Oprah and in publications, including the New York Times, Time, and USA Today. Dr. Goldman, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much. I'm so excited to be here with you today and especially talking about this topic.
她是纽约市的一名私人执业执照心理学家，也是纽约大学精神病学系的临床助理教授。她的执业重点是压力管理、饮食行为、肥胖治疗和健康行为改变。2011年至2016年，她曾在贝尔维尤医院肥胖与体重管理中心担任高级心理学家。除了临床工作外，戈德曼博士还经常作为健康专家出现在媒体上，包括作为奥普拉节目的专家小组成员，以及在《纽约时报》、《时代周刊》和《今日美国》等出版物中发表观点。戈德曼博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。非常感谢。我很高兴今天能在这里与您交流，特别是讨论这个话题。
So thank you. Well, let's start with a basic question. How do these GLP1 drugs work? What's happening in the brain and the body when people take these medications? Yeah, such a great question. So GLP-1s actually mimic a natural hormone called GLP-1, which helps regulate blood sugar levels and promotes weight loss. So now to kind of take that to easier terms, so to say, what I always hear with my clients is that it helps them feel full faster and it also decreases food noise, which is a new
那么，让我们从一个基本问题开始。这些GLP-1药物是如何起作用的？当人们服用这些药物时，大脑和身体里发生了什么？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。GLP-1药物实际上模拟了一种名为GLP-1的天然激素，它有助于调节血糖水平并促进减肥。用更通俗的话来说，我从客户那里听到最多的是，它能帮助他们更快地感到饱腹，并减少“食物噪音”，这是一个我们
term that we've been hearing for the past few years now. but it's something that probably you and I have known about or seen in individuals for many years, but now we have a name for it. So really what we're seeing with GOP ones is that individuals are getting full faster. They're decreasing cravings and this food noise, allowing them to eat less food, and that is promoting weight loss, as well as helping the diabetes. There's also new research out related to heart disease and other things as well. And what's happening to people mentally as a result of taking these drugs?
过去几年才开始听到的新术语。但这其实是你我多年来一直了解或在个人身上观察到的现象，只是现在我们给它起了一个名字。所以，我们真正看到的是，服用GLP-1药物的人能更快地感到饱腹。他们减少了对食物的渴望和这种“食物噪音”，从而摄入更少的食物，这不仅促进了减肥，还有助于控制糖尿病。目前还有关于心脏病及其他疾病的相关新研究。那么，服用这些药物对人们的心理有什么影响呢？
Yeah. So, I mean, a lot of things are happening mentally. And I think first, you know, I want to just mention that these medications don't work for everybody. So the things that we're going to be talking about today is kind of like what we hear most of. But I have clients that it's not really working so well for them or they have really bad side effects. So, you know, kind of just keeping that in mind. What I have really noticed, with my clients and with individuals that have really been struggling with their health and their weight for years is that these medications are giving them hope when they have lost hope. And really what I mean by that is individuals that have been struggling with these messages that we've been told for years, eat less, move more. All of a sudden, now when they are maybe eating less and moving a little more, they're seeing change. Whereas before, I think a lot of individuals that have the disease of obesity would be doing those health behavior change and trying really hard, but not seeing the results that maybe, I don't
是的，心理上确实发生了许多变化。首先，我想指出的是，这些药物并不适用于所有人。所以我们今天讨论的内容更多是基于我们听到最多的情况。但我也有一些客户，这些药物对他们效果并不理想，或者他们有非常严重的副作用。所以，请记住这一点。我真正注意到的是，对于那些多年来一直为健康和体重苦苦挣扎的客户和个人来说，这些药物在他们失去希望时给予了他们希望。我的意思是，那些多年来一直被告知“少吃多动”的人，突然间，当他们真的少吃并多动一点时，他们看到了变化。而在以前，我认为许多患有肥胖症的人即使在努力进行健康行为改变，却并没有看到预期的结果，
want to assume, but maybe somebody like you or I would, right? So for some people, eating a little less and moving a little more, works for them to get healthier and or to lose weight. And for some people, that doesn't do it. There's something in their brain that's telling them. you're still hungry or is really fighting that weight change or fighting the resistance and the medications are taking that kind of that piece away. So I like to say it's putting individuals that have struggled on an even playing field with people that really haven't struggled and that maybe going to the gym a little bit more, they're able to see that success and that change.
我不想妄下定论，但也许像你我这样的人，对吧？对有些人来说，少吃多动就能让他们变得更健康或减轻体重。但对另一些人来说，这并不奏效。他们大脑中有些东西在告诉他们“你还是很饿”，或者在对抗体重变化，对抗这种阻力，而药物正好消除了那部分阻力。所以我喜欢说，这让那些曾经挣扎的人与那些从未挣扎过的人站在了同一起跑线上，他们能够通过多去健身房一点点，看到成功和改变。
So I think we know that there are some positive aspects. to losing weight, especially if you've been trying to do so for a long time, and then you take one of these drugs, and you see it happening and you feel better. But what are some of the negative effects on people's psyche? Yeah. So, and I'm glad the way you frames that question, also because, you know, some individuals are also very happy in a larger body, and that doesn't mean that they have to lose weight, right? So some individuals have the disease of obesity or have struggled, and this is a goal of theirs, and we know excess body fat is not healthy and can lead to other diseases down the road as well. But some individuals, they have to be mindful of their weight loss
所以我认为我们知道减肥有一些积极的方面，特别是如果你已经尝试了很长时间，然后服用其中一种药物，看到效果并感觉更好。但对人们的心理有哪些负面影响呢？是的，我很高兴你这样提问，因为有些人对自己的大体型感到非常满意，这并不意味着他们必须减肥，对吧？所以有些人患有肥胖症或一直为此挣扎，减肥是他们的目标，我们也知道过多的身体脂肪是不健康的，并可能导致以后的其他疾病。但有些人，他们需要注意自己的体重减轻，
and we don't want individuals to lose too much weight, or maybe they don't need to lose weight, and they're healthy, and they're trying to get on these medications and losing more weight. So it really depends. You know, I like to remind people, everybody is a unique individual, and everyone has their stories and their struggles. So some individuals may already be feeling kind of low and have lower mental health, maybe have depression, anxiety, things like that. And these medications aren't necessarily going to just make that go away and or could be the opposite, right?
我们不希望人们减掉太多体重，或者也许他们根本不需要减肥，他们很健康，却试图服用这些药物并减掉更多体重。所以这真的因人而异。我喜欢提醒人们，每个人都是独特的个体，每个人都有自己的故事和挣扎。所以有些人可能已经感到情绪低落，心理健康状况较差，可能有抑郁、焦虑等问题。这些药物并不一定会让这些问题消失，甚至可能适得其反，对吧？
Like what is going on in your life right now is weight loss a good thing to add to the equation or not right now, right? So it's kind of like weighing the pros and cons and thinking where somebody is mentally and with their physical health conditions. So it really depends. Most individuals that I've seen, again, I would say that they are starting to feel better mentally and physically on these medications. Most, again, I can't speak to everybody, but most people as they're losing weight and they're getting healthier and they're seeing that what they're doing is working, they get a sense of, increase self-worth, increased self-esteem, increased body image. A lot of times people start to socialize more if they were isolating before, things like that. But it could work in the
比如你现在的生活状况如何，减肥是一个好的选择吗？所以这有点像权衡利弊，考虑某人的心理状态和身体健康状况。所以这真的因人而异。我见过的大多数人，再说一次，我觉得他们在服用这些药物后，心理和身体上都开始感觉更好了。大多数人，我不能代表所有人，但大多数人在减肥、变得更健康并看到自己的努力有效时，会获得一种自我价值感、自尊心的提升和身体形象的改善。很多时候，如果他们以前很孤立，他们会开始更多地进行社交，诸如此类。但它也可能向
other direction as well. So some individuals might be fearful to go out and socialize and go out to dinner because maybe they're only eating such a small amount of food now. And maybe they don't want to share that with others, right? Or they're not ready to share that with others. So again, I think it really depends where individuals are and what their goals are, but it can go either way, which is why I always say in a perfect world, everybody on a GLP1 would be seeing a dietitian and a mental health professional to help guide them and navigate this kind of really big change that's happening in their life. Well, that's an interesting point, and it raises a question of how people can think through whether these medications are right for them. So what are the
另一个方向发展。有些人可能会害怕出去社交和参加晚宴，因为他们现在吃得很少。也许他们不想与他人分享这一点，或者他们还没准备好分享。所以，我认为这真的取决于个人的处境和目标，但情况可能会向两个方向发展。这就是为什么我总是说，在理想的情况下，每个服用GLP-1药物的人都应该咨询营养师和心理健康专业人士，以帮助他们引导和应对生活中这种非常大的变化。这是一个有趣的观点，它提出了一个问题，即人们如何思考这些药物是否适合他们。那么，
questions that people should ask themselves or their health care providers before they start on one of these drugs. And if their doctor will even prescribe. Yeah. So I think the first question is, are you or have you been struggling with your health and or your weight, right? And I like to put that overall again because just being a larger body doesn't mean that you're necessarily unhealthy. So that's the first question. Are you struggling? Another thing I always say is if the thought is there, It's the same as I say about therapy, actually. If you've been thinking about maybe going for therapy, it's probably a sign. Seek it out, right?
人们在开始服用这些药物之前应该问自己或医疗保健提供者什么问题？如果他们的医生甚至愿意开处方的话。是的，我认为第一个问题是，你是否正在或一直为你的健康和/或体重而挣扎？我喜欢再次强调这一点，因为拥有大体型并不一定意味着你不健康。所以这是第一个问题。你在挣扎吗？另一件事我总是说，如果有了这个念头，其实就和我说心理治疗一样。如果你一直在考虑是否要进行心理治疗，这可能就是一个信号。去寻求它，对吧？
Ask, you know, get a mental professional. Maybe you have a consult. Maybe you decide it's not for you. If you're thinking, is this right for me? Is it something I should try? That should be a signal to talk to your health care professional about it. You know, make the phone call, make the appointment. It's been on my mind.
去咨询心理专业人士。也许你可以先咨询一下。也许你最终决定它不适合你。如果你在想“这适合我吗？我应该尝试吗？”，这应该是一个信号，让你去和你的医疗保健专业人士谈谈。打个电话，预约一下。这一直在我的脑海里，
Is this right for me? And talk that through with your doctor. because really it depends on your medical history. It depends on so many things that really just you and your health care professional together can make the best decision. Things I also like to keep in mind, though, is if somebody has a history of an eating disorder, I would actually really want to be closely monitoring that person if they decide to go on a GLP one.
这适合我吗？并与你的医生讨论这个问题。因为这真的取决于你的病史。它取决于很多事情，只有你和你的医疗保健专业人士一起才能做出最好的决定。不过，我还要提醒一点，如果某人有饮食失调史，如果他们决定服用GLP-1药物，我会非常希望密切监测那个人。
Again, there is this lesser appetite that comes. along with it, which means it's working, but we don't want it to work too well either. So, you know, if you do have a history of an eating disorder, I would really recommend not only speaking to your healthcare professional, but also getting a therapist or hopefully you have a therapist that can help guide you through this as well. I would say those are the main things to first get you in the door to talk to your healthcare professional about. And then, like I said, it's really the decision is yours and your doctors.
同样，随之而来的是食欲减退，这意味着它在起作用，但我们也不希望它起作用得太过头。所以，如果你确实有饮食失调史，我强烈建议不仅要咨询你的医疗保健专业人士，还要找一位治疗师，或者希望你已经有一位治疗师可以帮助你度过这个过程。我会说这些是让你迈出第一步去咨询医疗保健专业人士的主要事项。然后，就像我说的，决定权真的在于你和你的医生。
And I really emphasize the yours and your doctors because there's a lot of messages out there. There's a lot of opinions out there. And nobody knows what is right for you and your body and your health besides you and talking with your doctor about it. And I know we're going to get to the shame and the judgments in our conversation as well. But that's why I like to emphasize that. Because if this is something that you've been struggling with, this is a treatment option that is available.
我非常强调“你和你的医生”，因为外界有很多信息，有很多意见。除了你和你的医生讨论之外，没有人知道什么对你和你的身体健康是正确的。我知道我们稍后也会谈到羞耻感和评判。但这就是为什么我喜欢强调这一点。因为如果这是你一直在挣扎的事情，这是一种可用的治疗选择。
and it works for many people. Again, a lot of people have some bad side effects and things, but it works for many people. And it's something that you could totally consider and should be considered. Now, you see people in your practice who are on GLP 1 or would like to be on a GLP 1. Now, what if the physician says, I don't think you're a candidate and the patient says, I still want it? And there are places where you can get it.
而且它对许多人有效。再说一次，很多人有一些严重的副作用，但它对许多人有效。这是你可以完全考虑，也应该被考虑的事情。现在，你在你的诊所里看到一些正在服用或想要服用GLP-1药物的人。那么，如果医生说“我不认为你是合适的人选”，而病人说“我仍然想要它”？而且有些地方可以买到，
what do you say to those folks? And are there safer distributors than there are some better than others? Sure. And that's, that's a tough one because, you know, I don't think all physicians are really up on the science and the research and what's going on with GOP ones. So I think some individuals or some physicians right away are just like, no, I don't think you're a candidate. I don't want you want it. And if that's the case, if you feel like your physician may just not be on board because they don't fully understand, I would actually say to seek out an obesity medicine specialist and or see an endocrinologist that really specializes in this area because not every primary care physician is going to be comfortable prescribing this. And then, of course, you have the
你对这些人怎么说？是否有比其他更安全的经销商，或者有些更好？当然，这是一个棘手的问题，因为我不认为所有的医生都真正了解GLP-1药物的科学、研究和现状。所以我认为一些个人或一些医生会直接说：“不，我不认为你是合适的人选，我不希望你用它。”如果确实如此，如果你觉得你的医生可能因为不完全了解而不同意，我会建议你寻找一位肥胖医学专家，或者去看一位真正专注于该领域的内分泌科医生，因为不是每一位初级保健医生都会乐于开这种处方。当然，还有
individuals that I would say don't really meet criteria and still want it. Right. So yes, there's places out there, unfortunately, that you can get it. But again, I would want individuals to be really seeing a health care professional who is trained in this area and knows what they're doing with the prescriptions. Some people kind of go up too quickly in the dosages and then they have worse side effects. And also with any medication, they are tested through all the clinical trials. There's research. out there, their FDA approved and indicated for something, and there's certain criteria for a reason. So, you know, whenever we hear these things of, oh, this side effect or that side effect, my question is always, well, if the people that are on the medications or ones that the medication is made for, you might not be having some of those other side effects. So to just be extra mindful of that. And yes, we are learning more, you know, about GOP ones every day, more research is coming out, more medications or even being developed as we speak. Right now, they're once a week injectables.
那些我认为并不真正符合标准但仍然想要它的人。是的，不幸的是，确实有一些地方可以买到。但同样，我希望人们真正去看一位在该领域受过培训、知道如何开处方的医疗保健专业人士。有些人剂量增加得太快，然后产生了更严重的副作用。而且对于任何药物，它们都经过了所有的临床试验。有研究存在，它们是FDA批准并针对某种疾病的，设定某些标准是有原因的。所以，每当我们听到“哦，这个副作用或那个副作用”时，我的问题总是：“好吧，如果服用药物的人正是药物针对的人群，你可能就不会有那些副作用了。”所以要格外注意这一点。是的，我们每天都在学习更多关于GLP-1药物的知识，更多的研究正在出现，甚至在我们说话的时候，更多的药物正在被开发。目前，它们是每周一次的注射剂。
There's going to be daily tablets pretty soon. There's going to be weekly tablets. There's all these things in the works coming out. So we're learning more every day also. But I would really want individuals listening to go to a health care professional that is up in the research and is trained in this area. And that might need seeing an endocrinologist or an obesity medicine specialist. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Goldman about why there's still a stigma around GLP1 use and how patients can navigate and protect themselves from that.
很快就会有每日一次的药片。会有每周一次的药片。所有这些东西都在研发中。所以我们每天也在学习更多。但我真的希望听众去咨询一位了解研究并受过该领域培训的医疗保健专业人士。这可能需要去看内分泌科医生或肥胖医学专家。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与戈德曼博士讨论为什么围绕GLP-1药物的使用仍然存在污名化，以及患者如何应对并保护自己免受这种影响。
Wishing you could be there live for the big game, soaking up the atmosphere in the crowd, but too often, life gets busy or the price hold you back. Price Line is here to help you make it happen. With millions of deals on flights, hotels, and rental cars, you can go see the game live. Don't just dream about the trip. Book it with Priceline. Download the Priceline app or visit priceline.com. Actual prices may vary, limited time offer. Let's talk about stigma. You know, we've been sort of dancing around that. There's long been weight stigma in our society, and now people are facing stigma around the GLP1 drugs. Like, there's an idea that people are somehow cheating and not
希望你能亲临现场观看大型比赛，沉浸在人群的氛围中，但生活往往太忙碌，或者价格让你望而却步。Priceline在这里帮助你实现愿望。通过数以百万计的机票、酒店和租车优惠，你可以去现场观看比赛。不要只是梦想旅行。用Priceline预订吧。下载Priceline应用程序或访问priceline.com。实际价格可能会有所不同，限时优惠。让我们谈谈污名化。你知道，我们一直在绕着这个话题转。我们的社会长期以来一直存在体重污名化，现在人们正面临围绕GLP-1药物的污名化。比如，有一种观点认为人们是在作弊，没有
losing weight the right way. How can people do that? deal with these judgments from others and even from themselves. Yeah. It's so unfortunate because I think individuals experienced stigma and shame when they weren't getting treatment, right? And now they're experiencing stigma and shame when they are getting treatment. So it's almost like it's a no-win situation, which really sucks. And I really, you know, I hate that for my clients.
以正确的方式减肥。人们该如何应对这些来自他人甚至自身的评判呢？是的。这太不幸了，因为我认为人们在没有接受治疗时会经历污名化和羞耻感，对吧？而现在，当他们接受治疗时，他们又在经历污名化和羞耻感。所以这几乎是一个“双输”的局面，这真的很糟糕。我真的为我的客户感到难过。
I hate that for people listening and that are experiencing that. because unfortunately we live in a world that judges. As humans, we judge, unfortunately again. We do. But we live in a world that really stigmatizes individuals in larger bodies and or now, quote, taking the easy way out. I don't believe that that's the case, which is why I said, quote. But so it's very difficult. And I don't want to sit here saying, just ignore that because it's difficult and people internalize those messages. and then experience, you know, their own shame and stigma around it as well. So a few things I want to say about that is first, yes, we live in a society, unfortunately, that I think has glorified or thrived on thinness.
我为听众和正在经历这些的人感到难过。因为不幸的是，我们生活在一个喜欢评判的世界里。作为人类，不幸的是，我们确实会评判。我们确实会。但我们生活在一个真正污名化大体型人群，或者现在所谓的“走捷径”人群的世界里。我不认为事实是这样，这就是为什么我用了“所谓”这个词。但这非常困难。我不想坐在这里说“只要忽略它”，因为这很难，人们会内化这些信息，
And I think that's, of course, kind of where this begins and part of the problem. For years, we've all seen the magazines, the media and all of this about lose weight, lose weight, lose weight. So there's that. And because of that, individuals have internalized that and think that being thin is better. That's not necessarily the truth. You know, individuals can be in a thin or smaller body and not be healthy, just like individuals can be in a larger body and healthy or not healthy. Again, a decision for you and your health care team.
然后也会经历他们自己的羞耻感和污名化。所以关于这一点，我想说几点。首先，是的，我们生活在一个不幸的社会中，我认为这个社会美化或推崇瘦。我认为这当然是问题的开始，也是问题的一部分。多年来，我们都看过杂志、媒体以及所有关于“减肥、减肥、减肥”的内容。所以就是这样。正因为如此，人们内化了这一点，认为瘦更好。这不一定是事实。你知道，人们可能拥有瘦或较小的体型却不健康，就像人们可能拥有较大的体型却健康或不健康一样。再说一次，这是你和你的医疗保健团队的决定。
But what I will say is, A, you don't need to tell whoever you don't want to tell, whatever you decide to do when it comes to your health and your body. So we are not all out there blurting if we're on this medication or that medication when it comes to any other health condition. So why do we have to be telling people what we're doing when it comes to our weight or, again, overall theme of health? So that's one thing I'm going to say. And the unfortunate part is I often say this, but it's so true. We don't have post-it notes on our forehead telling the world what we're struggling with, right? But unfortunately, if we live in a larger body and all of a sudden lose weight or whatever body we live in and we lose weight, unfortunately, people's notice. Right.
但我会说，A，无论你决定在健康和身体方面做什么，你都不需要告诉任何你不想告诉的人。当涉及到任何其他健康状况时，我们并不会到处宣扬我们是否在服用这种或那种药物。那么，当涉及到我们的体重或整体健康主题时，为什么我们必须告诉别人我们在做什么呢？所以这是我要说的第一点。不幸的是，我经常这样说，但这确实是真的。我们的额头上没有贴着便利贴告诉世界我们在为什么而挣扎，对吧？但不幸的是，如果我们生活在大体型中，突然减掉了体重，或者无论我们生活在什么样的体型中，只要我们减掉了体重，不幸的是，人们会注意到。对吧。
That is one thing we notice. If I colored my hair, someone's going to notice and make a comment, right? That's something that we see. It's our appearance. But like nobody's asking what our shoe size is, right? It's our shoe size. It doesn't change. Well, sometimes it does.
这是我们注意到的事情。如果我染了头发，有人会注意到并发表评论，对吧？这是我们看到的东西。这是我们的外表。但没有人会问我们的鞋码是多少，对吧？这是我们的鞋码。它不会改变。好吧，有时它会。
But in general, it doesn't. So let's be quiet. when it comes to people's body shape and size, right? Don't comment on people's body shape and size. We don't know what people are going through. And especially because this is a psychology podcast, I'm going to say this also. Sometimes when you comment on people's body shape and size, you could be reinforcing a negative behavior, meaning somebody could be doing something unhealthy and you're like, wow,
但总的来说，它不会。所以，当涉及到人们的体型和身材时，请保持安静，对吧？不要评论人们的体型和身材。我们不知道人们正在经历什么。而且因为这是一个心理学播客，我还要说这一点。有时当你评论人们的体型和身材时，你可能会强化一种负面行为，这意味着某人可能正在做一些不健康的事情，而你说：“哇，
you look amazing. And that then triggers to that person, oh, I'm going to keep doing what I'm doing. because I'm getting on these conglaments and that feels really good, but it could be really harmful and unhealthy. So first role is just don't comment on people's body, shape, and size, because we don't know what they're doing. And then I would say remind yourself that you don't have to tell people if you don't want to.
你看上去太棒了。”这就会触发那个人：“哦，我要继续做我正在做的事情。”因为我得到了这些赞美，这感觉很好，但这可能非常有害且不健康。所以第一条规则就是不要评论人们的体型和身材，因为我们不知道他们在做什么。然后我会说，提醒自己，如果你不想告诉别人，你就不必告诉他们。
But I would say to try to get a select group of people that you can confide in or you can get support in because it's also something that you don't want to be fully doing. alone, you want to be able to talk through some of these things, maybe with loved ones, supportive friends. You want to have that in your life also to be happy for you that you are taking your health in your control and seeking treatment for something that maybe you've really been struggling with. But it's hard. I hear this from clients. I comment on it a lot in media related to, you know, this one must be on this because they're losing weight and like, you know, how to deal with all of that can be quite challenging.
但我会建议尝试找一小群你可以倾诉或获得支持的人，因为这也是你不希望完全独自面对的事情。你希望能够与亲人、支持你的朋友讨论其中一些事情。你也希望在你的生活中拥有这一点，让他们为你感到高兴，因为你正在掌控自己的健康，并为可能一直困扰你的事情寻求治疗。但这很难。我从客户那里听到这些。我在媒体上经常评论这一点，关于“这个人一定是在用这个，因为他们在减肥”，以及如何处理所有这些问题可能相当具有挑战性。
So I want to talk a little more about some of the psychological effects. There have been conflicting studies about links to depression and patients on GLP-1s. Where's the research on this now? Yeah. So again, I think there's more research coming out all the time related to this. And my question always goes back to, well, what were they experiencing before? Right. Like, we can't make the assumption that just because they're on a GLP one and they're having high levels of depression, that that's the link, right? We don't know what the cause is. Many times there could be a correlation or maybe it's exacerbated or not, but we don't really know. So, you know, more research is coming out on that and now that people have been on these medications for a little bit
我想多谈谈一些心理影响。关于服用GLP-1药物的患者与抑郁症之间的联系，研究结果一直存在冲突。目前这方面的研究进展如何？是的。所以同样，我认为关于这方面的研究一直在不断涌现。我的问题总是回到：“好吧，他们之前经历了什么？”对吧。就像我们不能仅仅因为他们正在服用GLP-1药物并且有高水平的抑郁症，就假设这就是联系，对吧？我们不知道原因是什么。很多时候可能存在相关性，或者也许它被加剧了，或者没有，但我们真的不知道。所以，关于这一点的研究正在不断涌现，而且现在人们服用这些药物已经有一段时间了，
longer because the rise of JLQIwans, I think, was maybe three, four, even five, you know, a few years ago at this point. So we really don't know. And again, this is why it's so important that you talk to your health care professional about this. Is this right for me? If you were somebody that's really struggling with depression right now and the depression is related to your wheat and your social life and maybe you're isolating because of
因为GLP-1药物的兴起，我想，可能是在三、四，甚至五年前，也就是几年前。所以我们真的不知道。再说一次，这就是为什么你和你的医疗保健专业人士讨论这个问题如此重要。这适合我吗？如果你是一个现在正为抑郁症而苦苦挣扎的人，而抑郁症与你的体重和社交生活有关，也许你因为
your weight, then maybe a J.O.P.1 might be a good option for you. under supervision with your health care team. But if you were somebody that's really struggling with depression and it's not related to your we, not related to your social life and these other things, maybe there's other things you should be doing first to get your depression under control and well managed before you add another medication that could worsen or better the depressive symptoms, right? So it's really a unique individual choice, again, with you and your health team to figure that out. You know, there have also been news articles recently about ozempic divorce.
你的体重而孤立自己，那么GLP-1药物可能是一个不错的选择。在你的医疗保健团队的监督下。但如果你是一个正为抑郁症而苦苦挣扎，且它与你的体重无关，与你的社交生活和其他事情无关的人，也许你应该先做其他事情来控制和管理好你的抑郁症，然后再添加另一种可能加重或改善抑郁症状的药物，对吧？所以这确实是一个独特的个人选择，同样，需要你和你的医疗团队来弄清楚。你知道，最近也有关于“Ozempic离婚”的新闻报道。
Is that something real? I mean, how do GLP-1s and weight loss more broadly affect people's relationships with their partners and their family and friends? Yeah, you know, it's so interesting those headlines because I remember it was a few years ago, could have even been several years ago, at this point, that there was a similar headline with bariatric surgery. And I digged into the research a little bit more because I remember being interviewed about it. And yes, the headline was like kind of true but kind of not true.
那是真的吗？我的意思是，GLP-1药物和更广泛的减肥如何影响人们与伴侣、家人和朋友的关系？是的，你知道，那些标题非常有趣，因为我记得那是几年前，甚至可能是几年前，当时关于减肥手术也有类似的标题。我深入研究了一下，因为我记得我曾就此接受过采访。是的，标题有点像真的，但又有点不是真的。
And what I mean by that is like maybe the, I forget what the divorce rate in America is right now. But whatever it was, it's like a, you know, not a huge number. And it was double that like for bariatric surgery. But it was a small number doubled. But like the headline was like post-bariatric surgery. doubles divorce rate. Like, yes, but a little misleading, right? So first, I just want to remind people, please read the articles and look at the research. Don't just read the headlines because our brain wants to, oh my God, is that going to happen to me without really understanding what's
我的意思是，也许，我忘了美国现在的离婚率是多少了。但无论它是多少，它不是一个巨大的数字。而减肥手术的离婚率是那个数字的两倍。但那是一个很小的数字翻了一番。但标题却像是“减肥手术后离婚率翻倍”。是的，但有点误导，对吧？所以首先，我只想提醒人们，请阅读文章并查看研究。不要只看标题，因为我们的大脑想要“天哪，这会发生在我身上吗”，而没有真正理解发生了
going on. But with that being said, any change. Now, the change could be, I decide to go to the gym more, so I'm not going to be sitting at home with my partner watching TV. The change could be we're making a change and we're going to eat healthier at home and maybe my partner's on board or maybe my partner's not on board, right? So these, what comes along with either being on a a GLP1 or Bayerathic surgery also mean other changes in your life. You're not just getting surgery or you're not just taking a medication. Hopefully you're making those behavior, lifestyle changes as well. And that could impact relationships simply by just making those changes without even introducing the actual surgery or GLP1 medication.
什么。但话虽如此，任何改变。现在，这种改变可能是：我决定多去健身房，所以我不会和我的伴侣坐在家里看电视。这种改变可能是：我们正在做出改变，我们要在家里吃得更健康，也许我的伴侣支持，也许我的伴侣不支持，对吧？所以，服用GLP-1药物或进行减肥手术所带来的，也意味着你生活中的其他变化。你不仅仅是做了手术或仅仅是服用了一种药物。希望你也在做出那些行为、生活方式的改变。而这可能会通过仅仅做出这些改变而影响人际关系，甚至不需要引入实际的手术或GLP-1药物。
So have I seen relationships struggle after starting one of these treatment options or after weight loss? Yes. And what I would say is my recommendation is talk to your partner about this ahead of time. Are they supportive of you doing this? I'm not saying not to do it if they're not supportive because it's your health and your body. But talk about this and talk about things that might arise, right? Like is your partner going to be on board that maybe you're, going to make a different meal for the household, or maybe you are going to want to go on evening
所以我见过在开始这些治疗选择之一或减肥后，人际关系出现挣扎吗？是的。我会建议的是，提前与你的伴侣讨论这个问题。他们支持你这样做吗？我并不是说如果他们不支持就不要做，因为这是你的健康和你的身体。但要谈论这件事，并谈论可能出现的问题，对吧？比如你的伴侣是否会支持你，也许你要为家里做不同的饭菜，或者也许你想在晚餐后去散步。
walks after dinner. You know, I kind of always use this example, but you have to create new rituals with your partner. If old rituals aren't going to fit in to this new lifestyle that you're trying to incorporate into your life, meaning if you used to sit on the couch and eat ice cream after dinner every night together. There's nothing wrong with that. But you might decide that you don't want to do that anymore. Or you might not crave ice cream anymore. I hear this often with people on GLP-1s. You might decide, I want to go take a walk or I want to go to the gym. Well, is that going to impact your relationship with your partner? Maybe your partner's still going to want to do that. What is that going to mean for the dynamic of the relationship and how is that going to shift?
你知道，我总是用这个例子，但你必须与你的伴侣创造新的仪式。如果旧的仪式不适合你试图融入生活的新生活方式，这意味着如果你以前习惯每天晚上晚餐后一起坐在沙发上吃冰淇淋。这没什么错。但你可能决定不想再那样做了。或者你可能不再渴望冰淇淋了。我经常从服用GLP-1药物的人那里听到这一点。你可能决定：“我想去散步，或者我想去健身房。”好吧，这会影响你与伴侣的关系吗？也许你的伴侣仍然想那样做。这对关系的动态意味着什么，它将如何转变？
It does not have to mean divorce, right? We don't need to jump to that. It just means better communication, getting the support, and finding new rituals that work for both of you. And I've also seen articles about something that they're calling ozempic personality, which refers to a cluster of mental health issues, including increased anxiety, depression, and a lack of interest in some of the activities you used to. enjoy. Is that another myth that needs to be busted right here? I think so. Yes. And again, we could say that about anything, right? Again, not to repeat myself, but kind of to repeat myself, with this medication, you know, hopefully people are doing the lifestyle and behavior changes. With that, other things change. So, you know, I do a type of therapy called CBT, Cognitive behavior therapy. For anyone listening that doesn't know what that is, the basic premise of it is our thoughts, emotions, and behaviors are all linked. So if we use GLP-1 medication for a moment as an example,
这不一定意味着离婚，对吧？我们不需要跳到那个结论。这只是意味着更好的沟通，获得支持，并找到对你们双方都有效的仪式。我还看到过关于他们称之为“Ozempic人格”的文章，指的是一系列心理健康问题，包括焦虑增加、抑郁和对你过去喜欢的一些活动缺乏兴趣。那是另一个需要在这里打破的神话吗？我想是的。是的。再说一次，我们可以对任何事情都这样说，对吧？再说一次，不是为了重复自己，但有点像是在重复自己，服用这种药物，你知道，希望人们正在进行生活方式和行为的改变。随之而来的是，其他事情也会改变。所以，你知道，我做一种叫做CBT的治疗，即认知行为疗法。对于任何不知道那是什么的听众，它的基本前提是我们的思想、情绪和行为都是相互关联的。所以如果我们暂时以GLP-1药物为例，
if you change the behavior by taking a medication and then you change other behaviors, that's going to change the way you're going to think about things, and that's going to change the way you're feeling about things. So it's all related. So could things change in your quote personality? Yes, know, right? Like, your personality isn't going to change, but you might not be as interested in, again, I don't know why I'm using ice cream as an example for everything, but you might not be as interested in going out for ice cream with your friends. You may instead be like, hey, let's go on a walk and talk and meet up instead of grabbing dessert together tonight, right? Like, you might want to change the way that you're living your life. And that's not a bad thing necessarily. And again,
如果你通过服用药物改变了行为，然后你改变了其他行为，那就会改变你思考事物的方式，那就会改变你对事物的感受。所以这一切都是相关的。所以你的“所谓人格”中的事情会改变吗？是的，知道吗，对吧？你的个性不会改变，但你可能不再像以前那样对和朋友出去吃冰淇淋感兴趣了。你可能会说：“嘿，我们去散步聊天，而不是今晚一起去吃甜点。”对吧？你可能想改变你生活的方式。这不一定是一件坏事。再说一次，
And, you know, and or I will say also, and this goes for anybody, if you're on a GOP 1 or not, if you're not eating enough food, there's realness to being hungry, right? When you're hungry and you're angry and you get irritable. So these are things that I am noticing with people that are on GOP 1s that aren't getting enough food or eating regularly. So again, GOP 1s are working by also making you full faster and limiting the amount of food you're eating. I just had a client earlier today that was like, she just upped her dose and was like, I have zero appetite. And I was like, that's a problem, right? Like,
而且，你知道，我还要说，这对任何人都是一样的，无论你是否服用GLP-1药物，如果你没有摄入足够的食物，饥饿是真实的，对吧？当你饿了，你就会生气，就会变得易怒。所以这些是我在服用GLP-1药物的人身上注意到的，他们没有摄入足够的食物或没有规律进食。所以再说一次，GLP-1药物通过让你更快感到饱腹并限制你摄入的食物量来起作用。我今天早些时候刚有一个客户，她刚刚增加了剂量，说：“我一点食欲都没有。”我说：“那是个问题，对吧？”
we need you to start, we need to make sure you're eating regularly. So for some people, it's a little bit forcing yourself to eat a little bit something. If any of us restrict what we're eating or we're skipping meals, we're going to get irritable. We're going to get angry. We might get depressed. We might lose joy in certain things. So again, you know, I think a lot of these headlines are making a big jumps and missing what's happening in the in-between. And again, this is why it's so important that people are being followed by individuals that are really trained in this to note what questions to ask, right? Like I supervise psychiatry residents also, and one of them had asked me one day,
我们需要你开始，我们需要确保你规律进食。所以对有些人来说，这有点像是强迫自己吃一点东西。如果我们中的任何人限制饮食或跳过正餐，我们就会变得易怒。我们会生气。我们可能会抑郁。我们可能会失去对某些事物的乐趣。所以再说一次，我认为很多这些标题都在进行巨大的跳跃，忽略了中间发生了什么。再说一次，这就是为什么人们由真正受过培训的人员跟踪如此重要，以注意该问什么问题，对吧？比如我也监督精神科住院医师，其中一个有一天问我，
you know, I have a client that's or a patient that's on a GOP1, with, they're getting really nauseous. Should I just tell them to talk to their doctor about lowering their dosage. And I was like, well, let's explore it a little bit, right? Like, what time are they taking the medication? Are they taking the medication on an empty stomach, on a full stomach? Did they drink enough water? Did they get enough sleep? Like, we can't make this immediate connection that it's just the dosage or it's just the GOP one. There's some behaviors that we can be looking at. And as a mental health professional, I'm not the prescribing physician, but I can help my clients navigate that
“你知道，我有一个客户或病人正在服用GLP-1药物，他们变得非常恶心。我应该告诉他们和医生谈谈降低剂量吗？”我说：“好吧，让我们深入探讨一下，对吧？比如，他们什么时候服药？他们是空腹还是饱腹服药？他们喝够水了吗？他们睡够了吗？我们不能做出这种直接的联系，认为这只是剂量问题或只是GLP-1药物的问题。我们可以观察一些行为。作为心理健康专业人士，我不是开处方的医生，但我可以帮助我的客户应对这一点，
and then say, now I want you to go back to your prescribing doctor and let them know. I'm getting really nauseous, but I also realized I'm taking the medication on an empty stomach. Let me try this before we lower the dose, right, as opposed to just jumping to that. And that's where I think, you know, this conversation is so important that mental health providers can be doing this kind of curiosity and investigative and navigation work with our clients and guide them in then having these conversations with their prescribing doctors as well. What about people who reach their goal weight and then decide that they want to stop taking the medications? What issues might come up for them and what kinds of support might they need?
然后说：“现在我希望你回到你的开方医生那里，让他们知道。我变得非常恶心，但我也意识到我是空腹服药的。让我先尝试改变这一点，然后再降低剂量，对吧？”而不是直接跳到那个结论。这就是我认为这个对话如此重要的地方，心理健康提供者可以与我们的客户进行这种好奇、调查和导航工作，并引导他们在之后与开方医生进行这些对话。对于那些达到目标体重然后决定停止服用药物的人呢？他们可能会遇到什么问题，他们可能需要什么样的支持？
Yeah, such a great question. We've been kind of hearing about this for a while. I have this question of when I get my goal weight or when I meet my goal week, can I stop the medication? And it's kind of a difficult question to answer. But the way that I like to answer it is if you have the disease of obesity, it is a disease that has to be managed for the rest of your life. So for most people, you have to have some treatment that you are using. And I say that vaguely some treatment that you're using for the rest of your life to manage it. That could mean just lifestyle behavior change for some. It could mean a lower dose of the medication for others. We don't know. But if you are on a medication for hypertension and you all of a sudden,
是的，这是一个非常好的问题。我们已经听过一段时间了。我经常遇到这个问题：“当我达到目标体重时，我可以停止服用药物吗？”这是一个很难回答的问题。但我喜欢回答的方式是：如果你患有肥胖症，这是一种必须终身管理的疾病。所以对大多数人来说，你必须采取某种治疗方法。我模糊地说，某种你终身使用的治疗方法来管理它。对有些人来说，这可能只是生活方式行为的改变。对另一些人来说，这可能意味着较低剂量的药物。我们不知道。但如果你正在服用治疗高血压的药物，而你突然……
your blood pressure is in the normal range, for most people, they're not just going to stop the medication, right? Like, it's working because you're on the medication. So I think that's really important for people to hear, again, if you're struggling with the disease of obesity, if you're on the medication just for weight loss and maybe didn't really get it for the reasons it's indicated for, I'm not speaking to that person, you know, in this conversation. But again, that's a conversation that needs to happen with you and your doctors. For some people, they're going down a dosage to see maybe it's more like a maintenance dose. for some, they might go down, dosing, and then try, I don't want to say doing it on their own because it didn't work before on their own, right? But kind of like figuring that out and navigating it.
如果你的血压处于正常范围，大多数人不会直接停药，对吧？因为药物正在发挥作用，所以你才保持在正常范围。我认为这一点对人们来说非常重要，再次强调，如果你正在与肥胖症作斗争，如果你只是为了减肥而服用药物，而不是因为有明确的医疗指征，那么我现在的讨论对象不是你。但这确实是你需要与医生沟通的问题。有些人可能会降低剂量，看看是否能维持效果；有些人可能会尝试减量，然后尝试——我不想说“靠自己”，因为之前靠自己并没有成功，对吧？而是说去摸索和应对这个过程。
But I do think it's important to remember the medication is working if you hit the goal weight. And we don't necessarily want to just now eliminate that factor because that's the treatment that's been working for you. So cold turkey is not advised. Definitely not. Again, I would be very mindful of even decreasing the dosage too quickly, like with lots of medications. You want to kind of very slowly titrate down and, again, be supervised by your prescribing physician in terms of how to do that and what that's going to look like. Anything else you want our listeners to know about GLP1s and psychology, physiology, anything else that, that, you know,
但我确实认为要记住一点：如果你达到了目标体重，说明药物正在起作用。我们不一定想现在就消除这个因素，因为这是对你有效的治疗方法。所以绝对不建议突然停药。当然不建议。同样，对于减少剂量也要非常谨慎，就像许多药物一样，你需要非常缓慢地减量，并且在处方医生的监督下进行，了解如何操作以及后续的情况。关于GLP-1药物与心理学、生理学，还有什么你想让听众了解的吗？
you're noticing as you work in this area? Yeah, I mean, I guess the main thing that I've really seen, you know, and we didn't really talk about it too much, but we touched on it is the food noise aspect. And I think it's really fascinating because I have clients that will start the medication. And for some, they notice a decrease in the food noise. Like, I like to think of it as like volume. Like, it gets a little lower in the volume. It's a little quieter, the chatter, the food chatter. And for some people, they're like, oh, my God, it's just gone. Like, it is gone. They have no cravings.
你在这一领域工作时还注意到了什么？是的，我想我真正看到的主要一点——我们之前没有深入讨论，但触及到了——就是“食物噪音”的问题。我觉得这非常迷人，因为我有客户开始服用这种药物后，有些人注意到食物噪音减少了。我喜欢把它想象成音量，音量变小了，关于食物的杂念变安静了。而对有些人来说，他们会觉得“天哪，它完全消失了”，他们没有了那种渴望。
They, you know, don't think about food the way that they did before and they can enjoy food and on a whole new level. And I think it's really interesting because I think decreasing that food noise is actually allowing individuals to work on their relationship with food and mean even to do like the CVT work related to body image or their depression or other things. Whereas before, the food noise was so loud that it really just took up so much mental space for a lot of my patients. So I think if you're struggling with food noise, you know, it's another thing to maybe talk
他们不再像以前那样思考食物，可以以全新的方式享受食物。我认为这非常有趣，因为减少食物噪音实际上让个人能够处理他们与食物的关系，甚至可以进行与身体意象、抑郁或其他问题相关的认知行为疗法（CBT）。而在以前，食物噪音太大了，占据了许多患者太多的心理空间。所以如果你正在与食物噪音作斗争，这可能是另一个可以与医生讨论的话题。
to your doctor about if this could be right for you. And, you know, everybody's experience is different. So I think if you know people that this is working great for, you know people that it's not working well for, or you know people that have bad side effects or you don't, you know, go into this with an open mind and just be very mindful and try to tune in to yourself and understand what this is doing for you. Because I do think that we all live in a society that we just go, go, go, go, go, and we're ignoring a lot of the messages and signals and signs that our body is giving us, which for some people, that could even be a hunger or fullness feeling. And a lot of people
看看这是否适合你。每个人的经历都是不同的。所以如果你认识的人从中受益，或者认识的人效果不好，或者认识的人有严重的副作用，请保持开放的心态，多加留意，试着关注自己，了解这对你有什么影响。因为我认为我们都生活在一个节奏极快的社会中，我们忽略了身体发出的许多信息、信号和迹象，对某些人来说，这甚至包括饥饿感或饱腹感。很多人
on GLB-1's also are saying, wow, like, I'm satisfied and I'm stopping. Whereas before, maybe they've never really were tuned into those hunger or fullness cues. And again, the decrease in the food noise is allowing that to happen now as well. So before we go, I just want to tell our listeners, you have a book coming out. So let's tell people what's the book? Once it's going to be available? Yes, I really appreciate that. Thank you so much. And although it's not about GOP-1s, there is a whole chapter on body image. And it is more about providing CBT tools to, people to help them decrease stress, build confidence, and break free, which is actually the subtitle of the book.
在使用GLP-1药物时也说：“哇，我感到满足了，我停下来了。”而以前，他们可能从未真正关注过这些饥饿或饱腹的信号。同样，食物噪音的减少现在也让这一切成为可能。在结束之前，我想告诉听众，你有一本新书要出版了。让我们告诉大家书名是什么？什么时候可以买到？是的，非常感谢。虽然它不是关于GLP-1的，但书中有一整章关于身体意象的内容。它更多是关于为人们提供CBT工具，帮助他们减轻压力、建立自信并获得自由，这实际上也是书的副标题。
So the book is called When Life Happens, The Mindset Shift You Need to Manage Stress, Build Confidence and Break Free. It is available now, actually, for pre-order and will be released. Publication Day is April 7, 2026. But people can find me at Dr. Rachel, NYC, on social media. or Dr. Rachel NYC.com. You can learn more about my book and pre-order it there as well. So thank you.
所以这本书叫《当生活发生时：管理压力、建立自信和获得自由所需的思维转变》。它现在已经可以预订了，出版日期是2026年4月7日。人们可以在社交媒体上通过Dr. Rachel NYC找到我，或者访问Dr.RachelNYC.com。你可以在那里了解更多关于我书的信息并进行预订。谢谢。
All right. Well, Dr. Goldman, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very helpful. Awesome. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review.
好的，戈德曼博士，感谢你今天加入我的节目。这非常有帮助。太棒了，非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》往期节目，也可以在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方收听。如果你喜欢我们的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can eat. email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。